[Music]
have you guys
ever done a contest for prize cash cash
prize
i think i did but i don't remember pride
like what kind of
content i don't know just like uh like a
singing contest the brand goes hey
hashtag this and do this or even like
back in the days they're at the malls
and then you know the malls have had
prizes i've gotten i've won like a
bicycle at burger king
i also won the gobot collection from
nestle quick
let's go bye it was like the before the
transformers or the gobots i won the
whole collection from nestle quick
i would call radio stations and get a
bunch of [ __ ] oh really
oh it's tight and did you always end up
getting the prizes that you just got the
prize is that the prize right
i never tried i never won anything you
never wanted
me neither i never tried i never tried
either so dude i was the kid that never
won
one at bingo at school like i was i
don't think i've ever got up and like
oh bingo and got myself a piece of
[ __ ] candy i'm like
how do you not win bingo i don't always
win if i
if i if i i usually find like
try to win something i will i'm lucky
you're just a lucky guy i'm born in the
year the rabbits i'm lucky
i met i met him at a poker table oh yeah
we didn't we're playing we should go
gamble with them all the time
we're lucky we did pretty good that
night it was a that was a funny grandma
do you remember that grandma on the
table she's so memorable dude
because she was so grumpy when she loses
but so happy when she wins
i hate playing with those people because
because she [ __ ] i [ __ ]
took her [ __ ] because you don't want to
take it from the little girl because you
don't make her feel sad but
don't give up i don't care i was
laughing at her i was like you shouldn't
even be spending that you probably live
at the trailer park stupid damn
i play really straightforward when it's
old people but then if they still lose
on me that's on you you're done
sometimes i'll get the cars up like whoa
and i'll bet on purpose and then they're
like they don't believe me i'm like
come on dude whoa oh it's so
exaggerating
that's what i love about the poker table
is like you
decided to put that money that's that's
that's ready for everybody's taking yeah
that's you man i don't give a damn if
that's your house payment
and that's your i can but they when they
start to
draw on your heartstrings like that you
don't make that bet but they could be
hustling you
are you lucky with raffles yeah i'm
lucky with raffles too
you're like my mom but the poker table
is the one place in the world where you
can tell somebody
[ __ ] you through money yeah without
feeling like a dick
well i guess for you you feel like a
dick but in the real world right i think
the equivalent to that in the real world
is let's say like i come in with the
business and i crush the competition
yeah yeah yeah right but i don't want to
do that because i'm like
well these guys you know they have
families
they they got to feed somebody right or
whatever maybe i'll
i'll lot like a trailer park or
something i'd be like i'll kick them all
out and build a casino there
i'm not going to do that but on the
poker table that's when i can go a
thousand percent
and i'm like yeah [ __ ] no i feel i feel
you because it's like a sport now the
evil
if you're good if you're like a lebron
you're just crushing everybody
well it sounds like competition it
doesn't sound like you're evil
it just turns out competitively you make
a decision they make a decision then you
make a decision they make it
fair yeah it's very very it's very fake
and hard they can pull
you like they recognize me then they'll
i'll play them even harder dude
and then they'll like make you feel bad
if you beat them that's when you leave
the table you don't even need the money
i'm like oh [ __ ]
like you don't know my phone at this
[ __ ] i'm not careful i'm not here to
[ __ ] school your ass
all right so uh back to uh winning cash
prizes and all that stuff
if you were not to get the prize money
for whatever reasons after you've
won i assume how do you how would you
sue them
so it means a lot to you to win i think
it's all about the honor
true what about five thousand dollars
how do you feel about five
i feel pretty bad five thousand enough
to get to be like make a phone call like
no what did i do to win
this pretend because if it was like me
going out of my way like i had to
put a lot of pieces together like you
know that's a lot of work mcdonald's and
[ __ ]
like i had to buy so many [ __ ] big
macs to get those little
did you watch the monopoly thing they
said there was millions yeah they were
not gonna win that that was crazy dude i
love i'm on the documentary right now
it's called mcmillions yeah make
millions yeah check that out
i'm not watching i'm watching i was like
i was like damn you're in it yeah i'm on
it yeah
all right so let's check out what this
guy had to do on his way to win
5 000 dollars
i thought he was wearing fishnets i was
like what you have to do that and okay
wait so he put a bong he filled the bong
with uh uh
beer and uh tobacco and so it's a bong
rip of tobacco
where is he tackle is that the mall
what in a in a santa outfit it's not
weed this is tobacco
oh god he throw up with beer beer and
tobacco
what is he doing here so hashtag
nope made me do it is the challenge
and this is what he's gonna do oh you
better give me my [ __ ] money
if i took all this stupid [ __ ] who made
him do it
no pete it's a sunglasses
[Music]
is it the same guy yeah sunglasses
company don't pee don't
come on
they told him to do this that's [ __ ]
up for the people having to clean up his
piss
true and vomit all right so this is this
is the back story what is happening
the back story is no pete is a uh he did
win so no pete is the sunglasses uh
company and they had a challenge via
instagram
or just you know with the hashtag nope
made me do it they wanted you to do the
most insane
uh stunt possible in public oh that was
pretty insane
and just and tag tag them with that and
whoever did the
craziest thing uh i don't know if they
did the metric by views maybe
um they would win five thousand dollars
if they were chosen did they mess up and
instead of 500 they added an extra zero
so like oh we can't pay
i don't know that's not what they did
they oh so no pete came through with the
five thousand dollars now the problem is
is how it's how they delivered the five
thousand dollars
in sunglasses uh no five thousand
dollars worth of their glasses don't
tell me he's taking doll
hairs i'm like huh we got you all right
so this is how they decide to deliver
the money what is that they put five
thousand dollars
in cash in a bible out of all books
okay they cut out they cut out a square
in the bible and they placed the five
thousand dollars
they're so weird because they wanted to
write on on the inside the bible said
saying
you're the chosen one yeah so it's all
like this big like grand way to present
the money to him
now the problem is it's so cinematic and
so epic
it caught the eye of the postal service
and authorities snatched it up and said
there's something wrong with this
what kind of [ __ ] money is this
where's it from they confiscated the
money
the guy never got his five thousand
dollars and now peter
no pete the company is looking into
suing the authorities over the fact that
they confiscated the prize money
so they thought like the through the
x-rays or whatever they were like oh
this is some illegal money
yes and it just looks like why would
they send cash
yeah i do fedex what does that mean
personal
delivery service yeah that's weird
sending money like five
thousand dollars through the mail
[Laughter]
i mean send a check things get lost then
mommy dog what are we doing
that's not true so are they paying that
guy 5 000 or they're just saying it's
gone so at the moment it's it's ongoing
at the moment so
they're they haven't said that they're
gonna pay him another set of five
thousand dollars
but they're looking into suing the
government right now
and what country is this thing this is
north norway norwegian customs the
government can
it's gonna cost you more than five
thousand dollars to fight that in court
true to prove that it's your money damn
it depends on how big this no pete is
how big is norway just running over the
homie over there
norway is pretty like it's compared to
america man
it's not that big right it's like
california no it's like
it's like up and down so it's like cal
california so you could [ __ ] drive it
over yeah
drive it they could have done one of
those things with the big checks like
they didn't have to do a whole bible
thing maybe their car was too small
because cars
give a homie fifty dollars to go deliver
five thousand dollars so
no pete on instagram has eleven thousand
followers so i i mean based on that
it might see come off like they're a
smaller company new company and their
startup so
maybe five thousand dollars is quite a
bit of money for them no no that that
looks like american dollars though it
was american dollars yeah america
five thousand american dollars what is
going on
so weird also it could just be a a a
a stunt that we're gonna pay you that
money but then we're gonna mail it to
you but then the homie at the mailbox
takes it down so publicity now you're
gonna tell the guy we can't pay you
because
and this is the biggest publicity
because now we're talking about
international news it's international
news but not only that
who's gonna question the government
taken and i like those glasses he was
wearing yeah those glasses are pretty
fresh they were like
goggles i'm gonna go check you out send
them over here
and know pete made us do it let me wear
them you know they look like
really fancy dental sick as [ __ ] they're
like the hip
asian mom they're like ski goggles yeah
they're huge
i love advisors yo no pete hit me up i
love it i like this thing this there's
like
one like robocop looking thing it's like
very uh
doc um what's his name from the future
no wait
yeah yeah yeah doc brown doc brown doc
brown from the future
that's true but yeah that's what
happened with that so
prize money gone wrong and uh
big [ __ ] fail i don't know
the population in norway true
[Laughter]
it makes me want to look up that hashtag
and see what other people were doing to
submit
true i you want to check it out i'm like
what are they doing i mean he crashed
his car he's as
santa claus taking a bunk the the bong
ripped with the beers
as extra like no one's gonna how do we
know true
that's too much peeing in your pants in
public is
kind of crazy but it's not very
fantastic it's like just you
and yourself you know in the states like
the authorities can just grab that cash
from you
if they want to and then you have to
prove that it's yours
obviously they could do that in norway
too yeah that's what happened
but if it's on you is what i'm saying
you get searched at tsa or whatever
they're like
oh well it's ours now and then you have
to
figure out there's only a certain amount
you can deal with you can only row
up to ten thousand dollars uh if you
have over ten thousand dollars you have
to claim
yeah you can still keep it they don't
think but if you don't claim it and talk
and then you don't have
paperwork or yeah and that looks shady
well it's something called the wire act
to like prevent drug
dealing in something and anything over
10 000 even banks
any transaction you had to tell the
government that this transaction
happened over 10 000
and they paid cash 10 000 that's what it
is yeah
but then now it's like also like let's
say you're traveling and then they pad
you down they're like what's this wad of
cash
they could just hold on to it and then
you have to get a lawyer and you have to
pay for all this [ __ ] and fight the
headaches it is man it's crazy because i
bought uh
my car cash and i had to withdraw a lot
of just
cash and i was holding it and i was like
[ __ ] dude this is kind of crazy like
at any moment a shady cop can pull me
over and if he wanted to he could just
take this
like poof how come you didn't like
withdraw the cashier's check or
something that's as good as
i want to cash i wanted cash oh you
wanted cash
i was buying multiple things so i just
thought that it would be better if i
bargained shady joe no but like let's
say you bargain a car right yeah you
like yeah
and then it's like you don't know what
number you're gonna
end up at so you you can't get the you
get the cashier's
cat check after you negotiate the price
you're so funny you're like the kid that
can't wait
because you could obviously you can
negotiate the price and i'll come back
in an hour
but you were like i want it now no i
don't want to i want it and i was buying
a mortar
you weren't calling that rubber band bam
bam
throw it out baller ass move i wanna i
want to buy more i was buying a
motorcycle in a car on the same day so
there was a lot going on
yeah so i i was checking out the whole
no pete hashtag thing and
doesn't seem like anyone else did
anything crazier imagine he's the only
one
well the other some one guy colored his
hair all crazy and
was showing it on his camera sauce
oh it's kind of lame another it looked
like he was a professional skydiver and
he just went skydiving
that's pretty crazy but it was i mean
for him because he he looked like a pro
he jumped out and he was just doing like
somersaults in the air and then he
pulled his uh
parachute thing so i'm like yeah she
should have peed while he was skydiving
she should have peed
i should've does the steady stream of
piss piano another plane that's flying
by oh
so there is their brand like like like
like a
energy like like oakley sunglasses it's
like something like
you need to run through a wall or
something true yeah it seems like the
the competition was not
norway she came out we pitched you some
ideas that get you this no pete fake
money
you